notorious negotiator
and a legendary legislator i give you
speaker
nancy delasandro pelosi
[Applause]
thank you all let's get to the point
thank y'all thank you mr chairman for
your very generous introduction i join
you in saluting our caucus for its
excellence thank you and
vice chair aguilar for a wonderful
conference mr president what you see
before you i say to them when under one
roof when our caucus comes together it's
the greatest collection of integrity and
ideas and imagination uh to make the
future better for the american people
they came together in this caucus under
the leadership of mr jeffries and mr
aguilar and our other leadership and we
heard from them we heard from members of
your administration we heard from
grassroots activists we heard from
actually we began mr president with a
prayer and it was a prayer to saint of
saint francis where there is despair may
we bring hope and you have brought us
hope now mr uh cleaver's prayers
have their own imagination
[Music]
but they also bring us hope so thank you
mr cleaver for your introduction your i
say your prayer
uh again
this was a remarkable few days because
it was it was for the people but it was
um
slava ukraine it was about
ukrainia
it just
mike mcfar others here have talked about
ukraine and how
what our responsibility is there to
those people they are fighting for their
country they are fighting for democracy
now i just say mr president it's an
honor for us to receive you any day but
on the one year anniversary of the
rescue package that the american rescue
plan thank you for joining us and thank
you for your leadership
[Applause]
you know you know and we've all talked
about all weekend millions of jobs
created under your leadership hundreds
of millions of vaccinations taking place
children in school people back to work
child tax credit so many things that you
made possible and to improve the lives
of the american people
and it is one year anniversary more to
be done what we talked about here when i
heard you say in that room and i've
quoted you you will be very pleased to
join in a bipartisan way for an
infrastructure bill but you would not
confine your vision for america to just
that and we have
other initiatives that are being put
forward as you said in your state of the
union address so clearly in your message
was about hope
it was about progress and it was about
empathy for the people many of whom have
not felt the full benefit of the upturn
in our economy but this election as we
talk about empathy
and you're under your leadership we talk
about equality and equity and all that
we are doing whether it's building
infrastructure
or advancing our economy to do so in a
new fresh way to not only help people
survive but to help them succeed and to
do so in a transformative way many more
women people of color participate in
that and you are making that happen with
equality equity with empathy for the
people making progress i'll just close
by saying
our democracy is on the ballot here we
know that
that
not every mr hoyer has told us again and
again that
the republicans are saying it's
legitimate political discourse
what happened on january 6. that's a
threat to our democracy mr clyburn has
said i always quote
jamie raskin quoting thomas payne
the times have found us yesterday we
were at the uh uh
independence hall and saw the pa the
reenactment of the peaceful transfer of
power from george washington to john
adams very emotional especially in light
of what happened last year and mr hybrid
says while we're seeing the times of
founders he says these are the times
that try men's souls another pain quote
so with all of that we have to show the
public the relationship between
democracy and their kitchen table
concerns
if the other side has its way in
suppressing the vote to printing the
vote and nullifying elections
what does that mean it means big dark
money dominate but the kitchen table
people
will not have the confidence that they
can have lower drug prices or
higher minimum wage or better public
education for the children or safer
neighborhoods free of gun violence
because that big dark money
which would prevail if the republicans
have their way
in suppressing the vote and in
nullifying a land so so much is at stake
nothing less than our democracy but
what democracy also means fair elections
mean in the lives of the american people
you have been
your time the time has found you this is
a president who has a great vision for
our country we see that every day
he has vision and values that go with it
he's a president
who has knowledge and therefore judgment
about policies that can work know his
you know his career i don't have to go
into it but we do know that every day in
his life he has made a difference in his
his political and official life a
president who is strategic in his
thinking who knows the path to get
something done
and a person with such authenticity
such sincerity about what he believes in
he knows that kitchen table his family
has sat at that kitchen table when he
was a little boy
when he was a little boy in pennsylvania
and then moved
to delaware so again god has blessed us
with the timing of this presidency with
this person who was just making such a
tremendous difference in the lives of
the american people so what a joy for us
to be able to welcome him as we discuss
how we go forward and how we impress
upon the american people that their
concerns are our concerns we sit with
them at that kitchen table and we are
determined again to win the election to
make the difference and our message will
be the message of the president of the
united states our special guest today
job president joe biden
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you please
i've been to enough senate caucuses and
democratic
retreats
to know that when the last speaker's up
we want to get the hell out of here
no matter who it is
thank you
look folks
i i me begin by saying that when i ran
and a lot of you helped me
a lot of good people ran
i made it i was running for three
reasons because i had no intention of
running for office again
one left the vice presidency
but
when i saw those folks come out of those
fields down in charlottesville
carrying torches and singing nazi
slogans and
carrying swastikas and white
supremacists
i decided to get engaged the point is
this
i
had a message which i didn't consult
with anybody about
generating to begin with
which was not viewed as being very
saleable
first was that
i thought it was essential to literally
restore the soul of this country
a sense of decency and honor a sense of
a sense that you could trust one another
to extort this country
because what we were seeing was not who
we are
and some of our republicans what they're
saying is still not who we are
second thing i wanted to do that's been
the essence of my whole career from the
time
i ran
20 miles from here a 29 year old kid for
the senate
was that i wanted to rebuild the
backbone of the country
the backbone of the country is a work
class and middle class
i'm so sick and tired to trickle down
when the middle class does well the poor
have a way up
and the wealthy do just fine they do
just fine
and the third thing which a lot of you
didn't like i know
i thought we had to unify the country
because ultimately we are a democracy
and there needs to be for it to work
there has to be consensus
the consensus you got to get a majority
we've not been able to do that for a lot
of the important things that's why we
have to continue to maintain
our majority
this off-year election in my view may be
the most important off-year election in
modern history
because we know what happens we know the
fundamental change that shifts
if we lose the house and senate
the only thing i'll have then is a veto
pen
and so folks i want to thank nancy for
introduction
for your friendship all these years
nance and paul thank you as well
and i want to thank
the extraordinary job you've done
delivering the omnibus
just like you delivered so many critical
pieces of legislation last year
and hakim and steny and jim and emmanuel
cleaver and pete
congresswoman catherine clark and all of
you out there
let me first say that
i want to thank you thank you for the
support you provided ukraine
i was on the phone today for a better
part of
an hour with uh zielinski who i speak to
almost daily the people who through
ukraine
have demonstrated a remarkable source of
bravery and courage
but the security assistance that you
provide has been absolutely critical
critical in their defense
second i want to thank you for showing a
unified front to the world
when putin unleashed his assault he
thought he could divide nato he thought
he could literally divide this country
the west the united states in terms of
the parties i know a former ambassador
knows that out there
he thought he could divide democrats and
republicans at home
but he failed
he failed
for months the united states has worked
tirelessly to keep our allies and
partners together
as our former ambassador you see on
television a lot thank god i will tell
you i've spent literally hours and hours
and hours and hours
keeping the
alliance together
the eu
nato and all of our allies including our
asian allies
as a result we've been able to ramp up
our economic pressure on putin
and further isolate russia on the global
stage
this morning
along with the g7 nations in germany
canada france italy japan and the united
kingdom
we moved which i know you wanted to do
in italy
and that drove her crazy on most favored
nation status as we call the united
states permanent normal trade relations
eliminate them
but folks
[Applause]
i know of occasionally frustrated you
but more important than us moving when
we want to
is making sure all of nato is together
is together
they have different vulnerabilities than
we do
just like in the oil embargo
a lot of them could not the only way i
was took
i think you know weeks to work out i
said we're going to block oil
russian oil energy we
consume 15 of it
they rely
totally on it
without russian oil
they're going to find themselves in a
position where they get choked off in a
way that
far exceeds anything we do
anything we do
so it took a long time sitting with my
counterparts and saying look
we're going to block oil but i'm not
going to ask you to do it i'm going to
say to you you do what you can i'm going
to explain why it's not rational for you
to do the same thing
in the meantime we're going to help
you get energy
through liquefied natural gas and a
whole range of other things the point is
revoking pntr for russia
has made it harder for russia
to do business with the united states
but in doing it with unison with our
allies
that kept to kept together make up half
the global economy
half of it it's a crushing blow to
russia
along with our partners and allies we've
stepped up pressure on corrupt russian
billionaires
we're increasing we're increasing
coordination among the g7 countries
and to target capture the new begotten
gains the yachts you see 70 shots 450
feet long
no i'm serious
hundreds of millions of dollars in value
for luxury apartments totality of our
economic sanctions and export controls
are crushing
crushing the russian economy
ruble has lost i know many of you know
this in detail lost more than half its
value
you know what the value of a ruble is
versus a dollar
you need 200 rubles to equal one dollar
today 200.
moscow stock exchange is closed for a
simple reason i get asked well why is it
closed
because for the last two weeks because
the moment it opens it will be disbanded
you hear me
it will blow up
credit rating agencies have downgraded
russia's government to junk status
junk status
the list of private business
international corporations leaving
russia is growing day by day by day
i want to be clear though
we're going to make sure ukraine has
weapons to defend themselves from
invading russian force
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
we will send money and food aid to save
your ukrainian lives
we're going to welcome ukrainian
refugees with open arms if in fact they
come all the way here
and as we provide
as we pride this supports ukraine we're
going to continue to stand together with
eyes in europe and send unmistakable
message
that we will defend
every inch of nato territory every
single inch
with the united galvanized nato
one movement that's why i moved over 12
000 american forces along the borders
with russia latvia estonia lithuania
romania etc
because they move once
granted if we respond it is world war
iii but we have a sacred obligation
on nato territory a sacred obligation
article 5
and we will not although we will not
fight the third world war in ukraine
putin's war against ukraine will never
be a victory democrats are rising to
meet the moment relying
rallying the world on the side of peace
and security
we're showing a strength and we'll never
falter but look
the idea
the idea that we're going to send in
offensive equipment and have planes and
tanks and trains
going in with american pilots and
american crews
just understand
don't kid yourself no matter what you
all say
that's called world war
iii
okay
let's get it straight here guys
that all expression don't kid a kidder
and i'd like to speak
to our broader purpose here today
to remind everybody
where we were a year ago
where we've gotten sensed
the direction we're headed in
and all of you know that today's the day
anniversary is as nancy said
since we passed the american rescue plan
within the first month of an office
thank god thank god you did it
and anybody's thought we're going to
pass a bill is 1 trillion 900 billion
dollars
we're going to do that yeah you did it
i asked and you did it
few pieces of legislation no hyperbole
in american history
have done more to lift this country out
of a crisis than what you did
it took about two million americans
before i was
before i sworn in two million americans
had been vaccinated
today
because of the efforts you what you
voted for
we have more than 250 million americans
fully vaccinated you'll remember the
lines of cars remember nice-looking cars
stretched for hours and hours to moking
just to get a box of food
well guess what
stretching those miles and miles no
longer is happening that box it's a food
it's not only a table in the trunk
because of that law
41 million people
put food on the table and put it on the
table who wouldn't have been able to
because of that law
we helped to keep over four million
people's heads who were about to be
evicted
and we gave families when my dad used to
call just a little bit of breathing room
just a little bit of breathing room
because we took action we created we
created 6.7 million jobs last year more
than any other time in american history
and we hadn't stopped last month we
created over seven
678 000 jobs in february to get us well
over seven million jobs
unemployment is down 3.8
economy grew 5.7 the best economic
growth in the last four decades
and the leading financial firm on wall
street moody's estimation because of the
rescue plan
four million more jobs are created
unemployment is two percent lower than
it would have been
and had we failed to ask
and it didn't cause the inflation
look there's more to the story than that
many of you remember and when we went
through that last financial crisis in
2008 i had to do resistance to the
president standing before all of you and
said and sheriff joe is going to take
care of the recovery act
well guess what
the economy recovered but underneath the
recovery
just like like every other recovery in
our history there was a lot of pain
a lot of pain
republicans in congress refused to give
president obama the additional recovery
funds he asked for and the truth is
a lot of folks never got back on their
feet
a whole lot of young people saw their
futures dim diminished they didn't get
back on track
and what's economists called the
economic scarring that occurred a
consequence of that recession
the chronic pain
when an economy comes back but some of
the folks are left behind and left
behind almost permanently
trapped in long-term unemployment
evictions and foreclosures study after
study showed that when you're stuck in
that cycle has the worst impact on your
emotional health and that of your
children and your family members you can
imagine
and that's serious
so when i came to office in the midst of
this crisis i was determined not to let
that happen together we made the choice
to ask for all that we needed to leave
nobody behind
to minimize the pain and the
hopelessness and despair that so many
had just lost their jobs
lost everything through no fault of
their own
and look what happened
isn't just an unemployment rate has
dropped at a record pace
we also seen the biggest drop in
long-term unemployment ever recorded in
american history
nearly 2.5 million americans
[Applause]
have got to break out of that cycle of
long-term unemployment
we've seen the most significant drop in
black and hispanic unemployment ever
recorded
black employment fell by more than 30
percent hispanic fell
hispanic employment unemployment fell by
nine percent to 4.4 percent
we've seen the lowest child poverty rate
ever recorded 40 decline in child
poverty
the lowest
the lowest number of harmful home
foreclosures ever recorded
down less than a third of what they were
before the pandemic
record low credit card delinquencies
because families had money in their
pockets list goes on
we've got a long way to go though i'm
not saying we're over we're just getting
going
and a lot of work to do but never forget
what we've accomplished together
so far
and by the way the american people just
trying to stay above water don't
understand this
you tell them what the american recovery
act was they look at you like what are
you talking about understandably
they're like my family
mom dad four kids grandpa live in the
house in a three bedroom suit level home
just every single day figuring out how
you put enough food on the table even
when things are okay
well
and on this one anniversary the american
rescue plan let's be clear
we did it alone
without one single solitary republican
vote
american economist flat on its back
it was the democrats it was you
that brought us back
and you didn't stop there
you invested in america in fact you
passed the biggest investment of
rebuilding the nation in history
now it's true we got some republicans
friends to help on the report on the
recovery excuse me on the
infrastructure act
but we're talking how many in the house
12 13 14 or something whatever it was
13. i mean come on i was happy for them
don't get me wrong
and then every one of them got attacked
look but have you noticed that every new
bridge
trench dub put in
the take to take out
leads every trench dug there's a
republican
this is a great thing
wonderful
we did it
even mitch mcconnell for god's sake
you know as we say in my outfit bless me
father for i have sinned this has been
so much since the last confession
look
the simple fact is this infrastructure
bill is going to transform america i
mean not figuratively literally
transform america
that's already started
instead of having infrastructure week we
have any infrastructure decade we voted
for okay
we got 4 000 projects all across the
country including 1 500 bridges
industry player that are starting to be
repaired this year this year
people back home need to know what's
happening
by the way where's my pittsburgh group
where are you
they're in pittsburgh
anyway i just outreached out some
pittsburgh
that that bridge you saw that bridge it
was devastating i stood there about that
bridge
you had gone down an hour before i got
there
over 100 foot fall
only a couple folks on that bridge
and if it had been two hours later
school buses would have been filled
children would have died
i mean it was you saw the pictures in
the paper you ought to stand there and
lean over and look at it
look
we need to tell the american people
this law is going to create millions of
jobs rebuilding
roads and bridges airports and ports
and